hello
my name is sergey bratis i'm a program
manager at the darpa information
innovation office
and i'm here
to talk to you about uh
the program uh that uh ito has been
running in secure parsing which we call
uh safe documents
uh next slide please
or safe dogs
for short
it's great to be here and it's a
privilege to speak uh to
uh the group
that is doing brilliant projects such as
ever parse
you will see that our efforts are
in a sense complementary and in a sense
address a
different set of challenges
but there is a deep connection on the
fundamental research side
between
the these challenges
and i hope that
you will
engage
you will reach out to our fundamental
research performers
and
there might be a collaboration coming
out of this
save docs or save documents
is a four year program and it's uh now
in its uh third year
and it
has produced a number of results that i
will show you
you see the graphic here
next slide please
and
uh save docs
starts with the observation
that
we have we've had the problem of secure
parsing of actual information
interchange formats and document formats
since pretty much forever why is it not
solved we have a great advances in
verified programming
where we can
start with a specification
and
create programs that can be proven
functionally correct and true to the
specification
but the moment you touch real world uh
program uh programs and real world
formats uh the situation blurs
considerably first and foremost you will
not find a machine readable
specification your specification will be
written in english
and even though this is in english of
technical standards
it is still not unambiguous
as an example and this is our test case
in the save documents project let's take
pdf pdf has
over 900 pages of core format
documentation many more of various
related standards and we've been able to
identify and report as candidate edits
uh over 60 ambiguities which are being
corrected
in the iso pdf 2.0 standard
so
it starts with establishing a machine
readable
view of the protocol and this of the
format and this can only be done by
observing what we see in the wild
then we can actually hope to
verify parsers
with respect to how they
verify
validate
the data that they receive
now
you might say that this
is a problem that has been
a mainstay of computer science and this
would be true we have the chomsky
hierarchy of grammars we have
context-free grammars that
we have
all kinds of tools to auto-generate the
code to parse and we have the more
recent
advancement in parser combinators
that make it easier for programmers to
create declarative definitions of
programs
however
context-free grammars don't quite do it
for modern complex data formats
and neither do parser combinators but
with a different caveat
context-free grammars do not concern
themselves with the objects and
relationships encoded in
electronic data formats uh and uh
extracted from those data formats and
then passed to the rest of the code so
that the rest of the code has to rely on
how these objects and relationships have
been validated and whether they have
been all validated
a parser combinator can do that but you
have to provide
the code for verification in a semantic
action
and so you leave the domain specific
languages for specifying grammars and
you are again
in as a programmer in the domain of
unsafe code
where you might accidentally corrupt
memory
and make your parser as vulnerable as an
ad hoc he enrolled a parser so we need a
way of finding the objects and
relationships and specifying them
declaratively and creating the code
that validates all of those and can be
relied on as the front end
after which all the rest of the
verification
can take place
next slide please
and in this we encounter the messy real
world
in which we have to
comprehend what is actually out there
because even when a
format is standardized as a pdf has been
since
the iso took over from adobe in the
maintenance of its specification
we still uh
can't be sure
that what you find on the internet or in
your own stash of files is compliant
with the standard in fact you are pretty
sure of the opposite
over the years uh
repairing files or repairing small uh
benign uh or presumed benign male
formations in files has them been the
mainstay of all implementations
and they disagree about what they
consider benign malformations
and how they fix it and so there are
dialects that diverge from the standard
and between each other
this is a considerable problem
you need to
actually observe the data in the wild to
derive a machine readable
rigorous unambiguous definition of the
de facto format as it exists not uh only
as it is transcribed
then
you have to establish new type theories
for actually describing
those objects and relationships
and
context-free grammars or sensitive
grammars or dependent types only get you
so far
because the development of modern
data formats
has not heeded theory as much
and has created its own favorite
constructs
finally
we have to
make sure that
these
descriptions remain machine readable
and that we can generate code from it
from them that could be verified
occasionally we might find that
the format as it is specified cannot be
made precise cannot be made
unambiguous and
we end up with creating what we call a
safe subset
a stricter subset
of a data format which has code that can
be verified next slide please
and then of course there is the
moment of code production itself
and
we want that code to be verified in uh
the best proof assistance and logics
that we have
where we encounter the challenge of what
is the right functional correctness
theory for a parser and surprisingly
there isn't a clear answer to this in
the literature
not in general
we need a new type theories and logics
to answer this question
and then performance
is a concern because a
the code verified a correct may not be
the most performant in fact this is the
most common excuse in rolling ad-hoc
parsers well
we have to make verifiable
implementations also performant
and since we actually want a regular
programmers to write
and generate that code
and
handle the specifications they have to
be accessible
we have to hide the math
and
make it so that you do not need a math
phd
to parse a format
and these are the fundamental challenges
of the save documents program and i hope
to tell you how we are handling them
next slide please
so save docs has
addressed a number of formats most
notably pdf but we have been looking at
the
icc color profiles which are an
important part of
[Music]
modern operating systems
often in the kernel of the modern
operating system but also when they are
not in the kernel they could still
take down a platform as we have seen
with an incorrect implementation of
uh
icc profile handling in android recently
where a background would essentially
soft break the phone
we have looked at uh image formats
and at the network formats which is of
course clear closer to
ever parse
we have been able to point uh out a lot
of ambiguities and help eliminate them
from the iso standard
and uh we are
redefining
how data
data sharing of formats information
interchange permits of the future could
be designed so that they are unambiguous
by construction
we hope that
in
[Music]
years from now this will be the way to
define our formats
to avoid ambiguity because ambiguity is
insecurity
and so far our parsers have been proven
correct and those that they have not
been proven correct yet have stood up to
hundreds of thousands of hours of
fuzzing and billions of document samples
so i think we are
doing a will and getting there next
slide please
and of course you will notice that uh
there is a considerable
intersection between the fundamental
research challenges with everparse which
uh aims to produce
a
functionally correct implementations of
parsers
we have a broader
set of topics and a richer set of
languages
and dependencies to validate and to
capture but of course performance is
also important to us it's just that this
is not the single concern
besides correctness expressiveness and
being able to capture
real world
formats is important next slide please
and so
the program has a number of directions
uh if you
attended this year's
or previous year's language theoretic
security workshop at the ieee security
and privacy conference oakland
you
saw a few of those results presented
today i want to
tell you about some of the highlights
there are many more
and these are our data definition
languages which aim to describe objects
and relationships in actual real world
modern uh divergent
information interchange formats
and these are
daedalus
of the
play on ddl of course
in from the uh galwa
a performer on saildox parsley
another gdl from sri based on sri's
pvs system
and another uh development which is a
parser combinator
in c
which is called hammer and is developed
by a performer called special
circumstances the original authors of
hammer in conjunction with uh the team
from ibe
where
they help validate and verify parts of
it
i won't be saying much more about hammer
today
because we don't have the time for it
but
i direct you to the github
of hammer
and
parser combinators and c
what don't look at me like that really
you can do this
and you can keep the subset of c in
semantic actions to be very expressive
and very succinct uh being able to
produce very small very short runnable c
declarative definitions of files
last but not least we have the first
ever
machine readable
model
of
all objects in the pdf standard across
all
and it is called the arlington pdf model
pdf standards are named after places and
this machine readable
model or document object model for pdf
is called arlington
this has been provided by the pdf
association
and it has been published as of may this
year you can find it on their web page
and also on github
next slide please
i would like to start with daedalus
which is a
data definition language
that is expressive enough to capture
objects and relationships in formats
such as pdf this is a tall order
because uh it
takes
uh care of data dependencies which are
many
referential integrity constraints which
are many
and situations where you have to
switch to a different place in the
format to parse from there and then come
back
which is
provided by a new abstraction first
class input streams
and this code is available on github for
your perusal
it takes uh quite a lot from the
dependent type theory as you can imagine
but it translates to c plus plus or
haskell the c plus plus features
an ownership based model uh those of you
who are looking at trust might like that
and uh
uh there is uh a server uh a language
server which we could use from vs code
uh or emacs
when writing um
uh daedalus descriptions of your format
next slide please
so uh i will not dwell on the syntax you
will find papers published about that at
the
langsec language theoretic security
workshop
but of course you would expect the
combinator
language
flavor from that it focuses on data
dependencies
and
on
unambiguous definitions including
removing ambiguity
from uh alternatives of the way personal
parts expression grammars do
uh with a biased choice
and that turns out to be a really
significant way of
reducing the workload of verifying the
resulting parsers
we have tested it on pdf but
also on other formats for pdf it's good
enough for text extraction
and extracting which actual objects and
relationships
are found in the file which streams are
found in the file next slide please
but we've applied it to other formats
such as
a color profiles icc color profiles
in fact using our tools and using our
definitions we have been able to
identify and recommend some of the
ambiguity
fixes to the format but we also were
able to find that the
recent
issue with parsing
icc profiles with handling icc profiles
was um actually not the pro the format's
fault
and not the fault of the format design
at all but rather of the implementation
that took uh
to processing it
i would like to point out that uh first
class streams are extremely important
uh for being able to capture the essence
of the format in just under 600 lines of
code in daedalus and this is a
sizable and important format again you
will find it in operating system kernels
pretty much everywhere as well as in
really expensive imaging
equipment such as medical imaging
equipment
it uh incorporates an arithmetic we can
also which we can also model using the
expressive power of daedalus so we go
much further than syntactic
validation
uh which will hopefully help avoid any
issues with
parsers generated from our
descriptions in the future this is an
ongoing work
and uh we hope to continue it next slide
please
we have uh another competing uh ddl uh
based on uh a different
flavor of formal verification
with daedalus being largely based on the
calculus of constructions of think
parsley uses
as its formal workhorse
pbs of course has been around for a long
time and has acquitted itself really
well in code verification
parsley defines attribute grammars and
was the first uh
to our knowledge implementation of
parsing expression grammars are pegs
to be
formally verified and proven correct
this result has been published last year
for performance parsley defines the
syntax the semantics the operational
semantics
of an abstract machine
to which the parser is compiled and
executed and it's capable of producing
certified parse trees
that is to say proofs of parsers proofs
that parses are correct in the spirit of
translational verification
next slide please
uh here on this slide you see some of
the syntactic details of parsley
and uh of course it's strongly typed
with dependent types and it also has a
slightly different concept
of
streams and a stream support which it
calls views and buffers
so
again we have abstractions for nested
format types
and for referential integrity between
several points of parsing which is very
common in document formats
uh this uh is key uh to securing formats
like a pdf or jpeg or image formats or
self describing formats like the data
distribution service
next slide please
i can't uh
talk um
a lot about the parsley
abstract machine
but uh as you can imagine
memoization
is critical to parsing expression
grammars
and
this
and other
important operational semantic aspects
are captured in the formally defined
operational semantics of this machine
and from this machine you can further
just in time compile it or optimize it
but
this is a
an approach
that
heeds the algebraic types approach to
creating parsers staged parsing
and
creates performance parsers
that are also expressive and could be
proven correct or could provide uh
transition translational correctness
proofs
with uh proof of parts
next slide please
but of course uh
you need to use the
a data definition language to encode
something and that something is a
document model
so for the first time ever so far as i
know we have produced a machine readable
model of the pdf format the pdf
association
a performer on the save docs
has produced and published it this year
it covers every version of pdf spec
and does so in a no code way
creating a schema
for tsv utilities but of course it can
be translated to ddls
and it
helped find
a lot of issues with existing
commercial and uh open source validators
of pdf files because once you start
capturing the essence of the format in a
formal way
inevitably you encounter surprises that
even the experts that have been in the
field since its inception
might be surprised by
this uh model has been published and i
believe that this is a very important
advance in defining what the format is
and how
it
should be handled from now on of course
we also need to capture not just the
standard but
the
actual dialects
of the format
based on various generators
that have been used over the years but
now we have a baseline
of machine readable human intelligible
definition
to benchmark or baseline
those
dialects against
and this records uh the iso standard uh
for pdf2o and the previous standards
next slide please
and just to give you an idea of what uh
the standard looks now
you are seeing uh
a marked up
excerpt from the standard
from the actual iso document uh and uh
the tables would be familiar to you if
you are
if you are
if you've spent time with those
the uh our linkedin pdf model
interprets
and uh as necessarily corrects when
ambiguous those kinds of definitions
next slide please
and it turns out that there are quite a
few um
ambiguous parts uh in the
uh standards language for example
uh the ambiguity as to how far the
indirection may go and how far your
validator may need to follow a chain of
references
between pdf objects to extract what is
ultimately might be just an integer a
length of a stream
uh next slide please
but
it may be more important than this
your objects in pdf are of course
dictionaries
the type of the object is determined by
a key
but that key might not be there so your
render might have to take a guess
and different renderers might take a
guess differently depending on
how they interpret a particular
deviation or a male formation that they
consider benign so creating streams and
documents that are
interpreted differently and therefore
rendered differently the parser
differentials is very much a security
problem
and
we are addressing the ambiguities
that are at the
root of those rooting them out one by
one
next slide please
we hope that our arlington pdf model uh
will help everpass efforts
and will help any other efforts that are
concerned with parsing or validation
or comparison of files or a pair of
files because again for the first time
ever we have a
formal model
uh
an unambiguous machine readable model of
what the uh objects and relationships
are so i encourage you to look it up and
connect with us and with the pdf
association next slide please
and last but not least i want to
mention uh two tools uh you will see the
um
a link to the uh blog post describing
them that help you find
files that are polyglots
that is to say uh can be understood as a
valid pdf and valid zip and a valid
bootable of volume and a valid truecrypt
module
disk image
and a valid
sns
game
image
and
availa jpeg and many more
you can read about those in that blog
post so understanding
the
polyglot
properties designed into formats often
unwittingly
is what a polyphile
helps you do
uh from the uh uh trail of bits uh
working with uh galwa
and uh there is also the polytraker
pulley tracer pulley tracker tool
that uh helps you uh
instrument uh a parser uh that you have
uh in cnc plus plus
uh with a form of very efficient taint
tracking so that you can see for every
byte in the file
what a code handles it
and what syntactic or semantic contract
in the file format
is being interpreted at uh each point
so
this has been a great tool for exploring
existing parsers and we encourage you to
try it out
um next slide please
and with that uh i am uh out of time uh
this is a large program that has
produced a number of other uh practical
and theoretical results unfortunately i
can only select a few highlights which i
thought would be interesting to you in
connection with ever parse and your
other system design efforts i would like
to close by saying that
this approach
to
information interchange formats
is something that i personally believe
must become the very first step of
systems engineering
and uh
before you write any code uh when your
system is still
a collection of boxes and arrows what
travels on those arrows has to be
defined unambiguously machine readably
human intelligibly in a data definition
language and if you have a legacy system
then you have to extract
and back port
that definition again using a ddl
and the file and format exploration
tools we
have
an internet observatory for pdf in which
we have processed
upwards of 20 million files i think our
goal is 300 million
and our discovery
has uh
so far
been quite successful
thank you